[Music]
[Applause]
Rahm and I love talking about big itchy
questions is the Bible true limit all
the time I'm sick and tired of just
taking that for granted
oh yeah one on a space rock yeah it's
not attached to anything you are
hurtling through this planet and is
filled with Wonder and awe and is all
around you all the time you were taught
success but what you want is Wonder and
awe there was a time and I don't mean to
get all Andy Rooney Anya but there was a
simpler time that if you didn't know
where Tom Petty was from you just didn't
know your body is made up of somewhere
around seven billion billion billion
atoms every single atom in your body is
over a billion years old you alone are
extraordinary I just want one stone
person here like
[Music]